foreign
this clip has popped up and it has to do
with money and so I thought I'd play it
for you and get your reaction to it and
talk about it I can't wait you ready yes
let's see what he has to say
people always say like money doesn't
make you happy but it makes me very
happy I mean I like to have money
uh
uh take money's money's good and that it
if you have some it can take away a lot
of stress that a lot of people have that
don't yeah I mean I'm happy to say that
I'm
my rent's going to be paid
my kids are going to eat not everyone
can say that
um
after that you know
you look at certain things you need you
look at certain things that are luxuries
um I wouldn't say it it buys you
happiness though can buy you access to
things you may want and then like
anybody you know so keep an eye on those
things you want because they more
options don't always make you happier
that's good dang Matthew the way he says
everything is just so cool wow it's just
I could listen to this voice he could
have just said the ABCs and I would been
like that was brilliant well done so
smart but the the content was a great
point it's a great point because there's
one side of the coin that everyone's
like money doesn't make you happy it's
not important and as Zig Ziglar which
this next Generation has no clue Zig
Ziglar a motivational speaker but uh but
his quote which I think is just so funny
is like money is not everything but it's
right up there with oxygen so like there
is a level where like yeah it doesn't
necessarily bring you Joy but it brings
you a level of Peace because you don't
have stress about where your next meal
is coming from are you going to have
shelter even to the point that if you
know a family member gets sick and you
have money in the bank to go buy a plane
ticket to go see them like you know all
of those things it gives you the ability
to live your life so yeah on one side
people are like no it doesn't make you
happy and I'm like well no but it does
like he said give you access but on the
other end if that's the only thing you
live for is the number in your checking
account you are going to live a pretty
empty life yes I think chasing happiness
through stuff is never going to end well
because we know that money and happiness
there's not always a correlation there's
folks in third world countries who have
way more joy than most Americans do
that's right and they don't have a lot
of stuff but they still have joy which
is the end result I would hope of
Happiness which is longer lasting it's
not this fleeting thing of like when our
vacation and it made us it made us happy
and then we came back home and we were
still miserable right because you go
with you and when you have debt in your
life you know Studies have shown you're
not sleeping as well it has a physical
weight on your body and so I think
that's that's kind of what's holding
people back is if you're broke and in
debt it's going to be harder to be happy
yep that's the correlation yes there's
going to be more stress more anxiety
naturally versus yes if you have if
you're debt free and have an emergency
fund you have money in the bank that
money is not correlating to oh I have
that dollar amount so I'm automatically
have a better life it's I have the
ability to use it as a tool to better my
life if or when I need it yes and our
research team we've done this state of
personal finance study now for almost
two years and this is over a thousand
people so it's statistically significant
we use a third party to do this and
here's some things that we found over a
hundred million Americans now say
they're struggling or in crisis with
their finances so that's about one out
of three people yep fifty percent of
Americans say finances have had a
negative impact on their like fiances
that's interesting and because of stress
brought on by money 41 of Americans
report crying oh my goodness at least
once in the last three months that's a
lot of stress that's a literally a sad
stat that breaks my heart to hear that
and lastly 41 have experienced a panic
attack because of money at some point in
their life yep so it has an effect on
you and that's what's crazy is again
it's not just the financial effect
it's everything else it's the emotional
the mental the spiritual I mean there's
there's so much that money affects in
our lives so it's not just numbers and
that's the one thing about math or about
money that we talk about a lot on the
show it's not just about math so you can
argue interest rates and getting a loan
and using you know instead of paying it
off use that money to invest in the
market you'll make a better return it's
smarter I mean you can do math all day
long but that does not correlate to your
mental your spiritual your physical
health I mean all of that and that money
plays a role in all of that oh yeah and
a lot of people that watch these videos
Rachel they always come from like
celebrities who have a ton of money yeah
and I was like hey guys I just want to
let you know money doesn't buy you
happiness they're like easy for you to
say dude I know I know totally like I
would like to experience that yeah I
want to have a lot of money so I can say
that money is doesn't matter right and
so I understand where they're coming
from there's this angst about it of like
you don't get to tell me that kind of
thing but there's so much truth in what
Matthew McConaughey was saying and what
he really was pointing to is what we've
been teaching for 30 years which is
Financial Peace yep it's contentment
with what you have and that is what it's
all about and we teach yes build wealth
and give and that's great but the end
goal is not just that money's going to
make you happy so you should go get you
some yep the goal is get out of debt
have money in the bank so that you have
peace and margin in your life to focus
on what really matters that's right
which is your health your career your
family and yes some of the stuff that
money can buy we want you to have nice
stuff don't misunderstand it's great to
do that when you do it the right way
that's intentionality yeah and money is
just a tool it's a tool to create a life
that you love right and so
um that's part of what it's for and it's
not the end-all be-all in life but you
can use it to have access like what he's
saying to have options all of it so man
Matthew just bring in the just bringing
the Thunder Matthew well done we love it
such a deep thinker he is I respect that
about mm
is that what you call him is that what
he was Matthew McConaughey when he was
on your show was he like Rachel you can
call me mm call me Eminem call me Maddie
he wasn't on my show Rachel we should
get him on Smart money happy hour to
talk about this great Matthew
McConaughey if you're listening I assume
that you're a big fan I know we were in
your top Spotify podcast get in touch
with our team we'd love to have you on
but it's true Rachel money magnifies
we've said that before it just makes you
more of what you are yep so if you're a
jerk and you're a miserable person well
man you're gonna be a rich jerk and if
you're generous while you don't have
much you're only going to become wildly
generous we call those people
philanthropists and so that encourages
me yeah and it can be different for you
if you're listening and you're feeling
that stress you're one of those people
who has cried who's at the panic attack
who's felt that lump in your throat the
knot in your stomach you can have what
we call Financial Peace but it starts
with deciding that enough is enough
we're gonna make some changes in our
life do whatever it takes draw the line
in the sand to change our family tree
and do something different